donc moi je voudrais dire qu'il y a il y
a un point qui correspond à des sujets
que nous avons évoqué à plusieurs
reprises qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
présent dans le texte du Gouvernement
c'est la question de la sécurité des
installations nucléaires civiles nous
avons à plusieurs reprises indiquées que
l'ASN estimait là encore au vu de retour
d'expérience internationale tous nos
homologues à l'étranger pour les
installations nucléaires civiles ont en
charge la Sûreté Nucléaire ce que nous
faisons mais aussi la sécurité c'est
quoi la sécurité c'est la lutte contre
les actes de malveillance bien sûr il y
a la cybersécurité dedans mais il y a
d'autres choses il y a l'intrusion etc
parce que c'est intimement lié quand on
regarde bien évidemment le
dimensionnement d'une installation
nucléaire et on l'a on a dimensionne par
rapport au risque accidentel mais aussi
par rapport au risque d'agression un
risque d'agression malveillante et je
pense c'est aussi un point que j'avais
cité ici madame la Présidente lors de la
table ronde sur le nouveau nucléaire que
ce sujet va être particulièrement
important pour les SMS dès lors que les
SMR ne seront pas installé sur les sites
nucléaires actuels parce que si on veut
véritablement avoir un effet
d'entraînement et de développement il va
falloir les mettre ailleurs et ben il y
aura ailleurs les sujets qui se poseront
en termes de sécurité et de sûreté on ne
peut pas imaginer la sécurité d'une
petite installation de la même manière
d'une grosse avec des barbelés des
gendarmes etc ce n'est pas la même chose
donc je pense qu'il y a il y a là un
manque dans le projet qui vous est
proposé qui vous sera proposé en tout
cas qui est proposé au Parlement il y a
dans la définition des missions que
l'ASN pourrait accueillir et qui sont
aujourd'hui exercés par l'IRSN il y a la
mission de dans le domaine de
l'expertise liée à la sécurité des
installations civiles qui n'est pas
explicitement présente et il me semble
qu'il faudrait l'ajouter à l'ensemble
des missions qui seraient transférée de
l'IRSN à la SN c'est bien une mission
d'expertise c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
toujours une autorité de de sécurité
mais la mission d'expertise va conserver
et ça permet d'avoir un niveau homogène
entre
l'ensemble des installations sur un
certain nombre de de sujets transversaux